everything that you want is on the other
side of hard if you fall in love with
the work aspect of it the success in the
accolades that come with it but you got
to fall in love with the work
you are in for a treat today one of the
greatest basketball players of all time
is in the house and it is a banger
that is Chris Paul's Chris Paul he is
the point God you've got old Chris Paul
down at the end the Great point guards
in the history of the game an Olympian
president of the NBA Players Association
and if you didn't know now you know
sport has taught me everything in life
it's taught me about sacrifice hard work
it's taught me about pain what was it
about your grandfather that made him
such an indelible figure in your life
the day before Jones was killed he was
here watching his grandson sign with
Wake Forest that Wake Forest hat that
Chris is wearing in that shot
Chris sees on a plan to honor his
grandfather in his next game scoring one
point for every year of his
grandfather's life
it just made me feel different
man
this ain't supposed to be this kind of
podcast he can now add author to his
long list of accomplishments his Memoir
entitled 61 is a really beautiful book
and it Chronicles his life both on and
off the court and the important role
that his grandfather played in molding
him into the man and the father he is
today we talk about Legacy fatherhood
leadership the importance of mentorship
and work ethic and how he is leveraging
his voice for maximum social impact not
just as an athlete but as a Storyteller
as an entrepreneur and as a
philanthropist so get into it and enjoy
we're brought to you today by Roka
would you ever do that on Ultra
endurance stuff no way the ultra is nuts
he did those what did you oh yeah that's
my whole deal
huh yeah man that's that's my whole trip
it's this whole thing hold up timeout
yeah
I wrote a book about it I'll give it to
you
that's how he got that's that's how this
whole thing started yeah following group
ultra distance so ultra marathon I was
just telling that Jesse is losing my
fantasy football league oh yeah yeah
he's a he's a really good buddy of mine
Jesse Yeah Jesse literally texted me
this morning he did
well like let's just send him a photo
right now
listen
Jessie's been in my fantasy football
league for a long time too Jesse texted
me this morning congrats on the book
that's super exciting oh cool but
Jesse's Jesse's email and Instagram for
the longest time was 100 mile man yeah
or whatnot right yeah yeah so Warriors
I seen him run like that one thing you
probably know about it what's the thing
when at night you
you run on this Trail
like you start like say you start at two
o'clock
you start running and then whatever time
you get back it like starts again at
like
standing that oh the Big's backyard yeah
yeah no no the last minute you do the
loop and then you do the loop on the
hour until everybody you know craps out
man listen
I followed I followed that whole
situation right because it was it's like
a day it's like a whole day go by and
you still running
oh it goes on for days yeah it goes on
longer than that and what's so important
about it and why like I appreciate that
stuff is watching the team like the team
of people so for you to do the
the ultra Ultra Man how many people did
you have on your team so Trapper was on
my crew it was my family in 2009 when I
did it yeah but then we had we had Alan
also
yeah five people in a van yeah we see
the people in a van got your food got
the recovery team sport you can't do
that [__] alone no you know and crewing
for those races is is extremely
demanding you know people think how hard
can it be just hand them a bottle you
make sure they're fed
um but you know Trapper can tell you
like it's it's exhausting and these guys
have done like Jason's done 100 Miler
Blake's done what's the longest one and
you haven't done 100 yeah yeah 50k so
is the swimming
that's my background though that's the
easy part no so my trainer when I played
for the Clippers uh his name was
um Richard Williams he was our head
trainer for the Clippers and what I
appreciated about him was that
we would travel on a road trip and get
into a city at one o'clock and Rich
would get up at 6 a.m 7 A.M because he
was training for
um like an Iron Man or something an Iron
Man yeah right and I went to San Diego
to he didn't even know I was coming he
had a what's the thing like before Iron
Man like the smaller one half the half
Iron Man
I drove to San Diego to surprise him and
showed up for him you know what I mean
yeah just showed up to to support him
and I watched him swim and then get out
and then you bike and then you run and
no way
Ain't No Way ain't no way cause he
talked about how everybody there's a lot
of track athletes listening right now
are very excited people kicking people
kick you in the water right yeah it gets
pretty hectic in the bigger races yeah
there's a lot of jostling around
climbing on top of each other
it's not as bad as an elbow in the face
or you know whatever you're dealing with
I don't think I know you're gonna ask me
questions but I'm so curious like what
so training for that
it depends it depends on whether
um what your goal is like you want to
just finish are you trying to win are
you trying to meet some kind of time
standard and that will and also what is
your level of experience
um so that's going to dictate like your
training program are you trying to
finish or were you trying to make a time
I mean I was doing it for high
performance so it was like a job I mean
I was doing many other things but at the
peak I was probably trained in 20 25
hours a week for a pretty good extended
period of time you have to put in a lot
of hours and it's just a You Know It's a
Grind it's a slog it's different from an
agility and and power and skill sport
like like basketball but it has its own
demands and you know particularly like
the the sort of mental fatigue and
exhaustion that you have to like contend
with but you know yeah I know it's all
hard man when you're trying to do
something at a high level it doesn't
matter whether it's a 100 meter sprint
or 100 mile run or you know what you're
doing like you have to you know
basically sacrifice a lot in the pursuit
of Mastery I believe I was in the gym
last night
um
I had a long day yesterday uh with book
stuff my kids
I don't even remember what I did
yesterday I just remember what I did
last night as far as the gym I went
uh somewhere my wife then I came home
literally got home got my son went to
the gym uh had a kid meet me at the gym
and we worked out for probably about two
and a half hours till probably about
eight eight thirty then took my son home
so that he'd go to the airport so he
could fly to North Carolina
and be with my parents for a few days
but the kid that I was working out with
is a kid named Mercy Miller who's he
goes to Notre Dame he's uh Notre Dame
High School here he's one of the best
players in the country when I lived in
Calabasas he lived down the street from
me and he used to come over my house all
the time so at that time
Mercy had to be like 12 11 12. but now
he's potentially
maybe a senior in high school could go
to college for one year and I might be
playing against him right yeah yeah you
stick around long enough as long as you
you've been playing and and suddenly you
know yeah you're like uh in this weird
multi-generational kind of space yeah
where you've seen it all over many years
but the stuff that I can appreciate like
you said is the the discipline aspect of
it so even though I play basketball if I
watch Like an ultra or if I watch a
marathon I'm I'm looking at what you're
doing
but I'm thinking about
damn you had to wake up early you know
you had to wake up early to train for
this like everybody see the finished
product but a lot of people don't think
about right the training that went into
it so like what was the hardest part for
you to think diet I mean I think the
hardest part is is just the Relentless
day after day aspect of it I mean I
think it's you know it's it's
um
you know just getting up day after day
the slog when you're exhausted and you
know you just don't you're not feeling
it and having to you know show up for it
with that level of like consistency and
intentionality over an extended period
of time
you know it's not I don't know that it's
any different
no matter what sport that you're in or
or even if you're pursuing some other
kind of thing that you're trying to be
great at you know it requires that level
of like focus and intensity and
prioritization all of it right and I
think
you know to kind of get into you know
the the actual podcast that we're going
to do like that's
um that's like a really big recurring
theme in your book I mean you keep kind
of pivoting back to this idea of work
ethic and hard work and determination
and and you use your grandfather Papa as
like a vehicle this Mentor looming you
know large and very important Mentor
figure in your life to illustrate like
how you you know sort of
um
uh you know inherited like that
sensibility that clearly you know you
are trying to say is integral to like
your success
yes absolutely and
I don't know I think like it's really
hard people don't realize how hard it is
to be good at anything but
the commitment like you said that it go
that goes into it
it's tough It's the waking up every day
is the
the the the one thing that that's really
hard and that's why I was asking you is
Diet right people don't realize how much
you have to plan
right you have to plan and so your last
one was at what age
last like last big race that I did yeah
I mean it's been a while I'm 56 now the
last really hard thing I did I was 51
but when I was at my Peak I was like 43
44. all right man it's a late in the
Life thanks you know
um and I also have like an incredibly
supportive family and wife and my wife's
an amazing cook and you know she handled
like the food part of that but yeah you
got to be really intentional about not
just your food but it is the the little
details like if you're running a
multi-day race
um you have to be so on top of all these
little things like do you have the
Vaseline that you're gonna put in
between your toes with this if you
forget like one tiny thing over that
extended period of time you know you get
a blister and you're done like one
little thing can derail the whole
mission so you have to be kind of
um always thinking about that kind of
stuff and being ahead of the curve on it
the one word that I know my son probably
hates to hear
like even even if somebody else says
this word I'm sure my son probably like
shakes a little bit right because he
just hears me say it all the time and
the word is details right so we're
working out in the gym and we're
shooting shots and my son will put his
foot on the line right shooting a
three-pointer but if your foot is on the
line it's a what it's a two yeah right
and
he'll shoot it and the first thing I
don't even look to see if it went in
first I just looked to see if his foot
was on the line
and if he make it I'll be like don't
count right because we're doing a
particular drill and he and I'd be like
details like every everything matters
not saying that you did it on purpose or
anything like that but it's those little
details that yeah that matter how do you
stay enthusiastic about that after so
many years I mean you've been doing this
for a long time right it's one thing uh
to come out hot as a young person and
you know be running and gunning
um and and you know make all of those
you know detail-oriented decisions
number one priority but you live a
really big life now you got a lot of
people pulling on you
um and it would be very easy to be
distracted or to start to just kind of
like
decide you know I got this handled like
I'm good enough like I got you know
another couple years of this or whatever
like so how do you stay
super energized and and you know kind of
on top of those details
yeah
um
it's a it's a competitiveness is uh
I mean especially as a parent to
um
so many things have been going through
my head at times if you just be honest
like there's there's this part of me
that's a caregiver too right when it
comes to providing for my family like
I'm also making ends meet to make sure
everyone is good there's also an ego
thing with my kids right and my son is a
Hooper yeah like I want my son to be
able to say
my dad nice you know what I'm saying my
dad can hoop you know that there's that
aspect of it and then the the big one is
just I just compete regardless of
whatever it is like if it's Connect Four
if it's uh we play horseshoes
um You probably swim a lot faster than
me but I'll try yeah I try I try as long
as my feet can touch the it doesn't
matter it's game on yeah I'm not
swimming as you're an ocean I need to be
in a pool that my feet are standing you
know what I mean
I just I love the competition of it and
the other thing is the appreciation and
the Gratitude and I'll say this because
I don't I don't know your family or your
upbringing but
in the book I talk about my grandfather
how he owned the service station like I
used to be there working like changing
oil rotating tires
um
my dad worked on an assembly line my mom
worked at a bank and I'm not sure I
don't think
my mom was like a little kid and someone
asked her what she wanted to do and she
was like oh I want to work for Wachovia
bank right so
I wanted to be a basketball player I get
to be a basketball player right so
why not
work hard and do all this different type
stuff because
I mean I I don't say too much but
when you were a kid
and like I said I don't know background
but I was like man if I ever got a
million dollars everybody gonna be good
right yeah I ain't no ain't nobody ever
gonna have to worry about anything again
but you start to realize and once you
start to get to know people and things
like this like
of course the money is amazing but it's
the work right so I know billionaires I
still work every day
so there's no like I'm gonna get to this
point and stop working yeah or or that
you when you achieve that goal or you
get that Accolade that you know then
you're gonna feel a certain way and have
this idea that everything is complete in
your life yeah I'm telling you it's so
crazy of course it's all these jokes he
ain't one over he won't know nothing so
um the the Nuggets won the championship
the other night and DeAndre Jordan was
one of my teammates when I played for
the clippers but more so than that he's
like my brother
I called him uh yesterday morning
because I knew he was out partying the
night before I called him yesterday
morning on FaceTime and I was like
emotional and just so happy for him
right so happy for him that he won and
he was talking about like see man I
always wondered what this was gonna feel
like or what that was gonna feel like
and you know he was talking about it and
I've actually had those thoughts before
like what would I feel like yeah when
that does happen and I know I'm gonna be
so excited and happy for my family and
everybody to be around but I always be
like you know that next day or even
after the parade you're still you just
knowing me yeah yeah I'm gonna be so
happy you know what I mean but I know
after that parade if not that next
morning the very next morning I'm gonna
be in the gym at six seven a.m you know
so yeah the hard work the grit
um but also you know I was listening to
you on uh on the pivot podcast and you
were talking about uh how you're a
people pleaser yeah yeah it's hard to
say no to people you want to be able to
show up for the people that care about
you and the way that others have shown
up for you over the course of your life
and your papa and all of that
um
but also uh you know that can those two
like values can come into conflict right
like if you if you've got to work hard
you got to put the blinders on you got
to go away you got to focus you got to
go to the Woodshed be with yourself your
teammates Etc and then the people
pleaser thing like with the life that
you live like you're a one-man like
Empire industry you got so many things
going on and I'm sure
um a lot of people rolling up on you all
the time wanting something and you being
a people pleaser wanting to make them
happy uh that can be without like
healthy boundaries or you know good
people around you could be you know
draining or or really kind of like uh
you know put your whole situation in
Peril because you're just distracted all
the time so how do you like work through
that
man it had gotten so bad one time with
the clothes where
I tried to during the playoffs uh I
would cut my phone off and then
I'd actually got like a chip like a chip
like a different chip for a different
phone number during the playoffs just to
try to stay you know locked in you know
because
distractions
they come even when you
try not to let them in you know but it's
always been tough still trying to figure
that part out because I've always been
um what's the word
I approachable but
accessible right and so you make
yourself accessible you know hoping that
people don't
take advantage of it or whatnot but
that's not always the case and then as
the union president for eight years I
had to be accessible I had to make sure
that players could get a get a hold of
me if need be or if people at the office
needed to get a hold of me but I'm
definitely a work in progress with that
and especially with my kids like trying
to make sure that they get that time
yeah
are you somebody who when it's really
loud it makes you calm like you there's
these stories of like brain scans of
high performers that you know when the
crowd is at its loudest that's why
they're nothing yeah it's like you're
just you're in that zone it gets so loud
sometimes that I don't hear anything you
know and that's
who knows where that comes from I think
it comes from a lot of experience but
there's a Focus right like all my all my
friends that I grew up with are my
homies they they always talk about
I so
I play golf every now and then right not
not the greatest or whatnot and golf or
whatnot but if we play for something my
game is totally different I've just
always been like that like I don't want
to do anything for shits and giggles
right like if we put a trash can out
there and then you had like balled up
trash and we shooting it let's shoot for
something there's no there's no off
switch it's let's for push-ups that's
fine let's shoot for push-ups that's
yeah it's really no off
um I watched that uh the inner you do
these these little uh interviews with
people for Bloomberg and I watched the
one you do with Michael Phelps so did
you I was like dude he's pretty
competitive himself right like did you
guys go after it man so the the cool
thing about Phelps man who and I mean
it's when I say that like Phelps is like
my family and we have the same financial
advisor that's how we got to know each
other and
I know I'm crazy but Phelps might be
yeah he's just as crazy yeah and and I
love him for it because uh
I mean we'll play golf together we'll do
anything we play cards whatever it is he
he's like that he does not have an off
switch
um in the book uh you talk about the uh
the the um the Jones disciples like the
guys that would hang around with your
your papa and uh shoot the [__] like his
close friends like his allies like his
inner circle right
um and I would assume in reading that
I'm thinking well you must you know
obviously that was impactful to you as a
young person seeing him have that
um
you must have that yourself right like a
core group like who's giving you the
honest feedback wow a lot of yes people
how do you know to say something about
that I would ask I know you do this a
lot but check this out I just got back
from Cabo uh-huh day before yesterday
like a trip I just got back from a trip
so
all my guys that I grew up with we got a
group chat right it's the best thing in
the world right it's like eight of us
and my brother like all of us in this
group chat and we talk just about every
day about anything in life during the
season when my game is over I can come
back to that chat and they might be in
there talking about how sorry I was in
the game they could be talking about any
and everything and
the relationships in that chat I cherish
right because you always think about
when you start something right it's kind
of crazy when you start it but then when
you look back on something 12 years 15
years you're like man everything doesn't
stand the test of time like that yeah
I try to take my guys on a trip every
year right after the season my guys I
try to take them on a trip and the thing
is is someone may say oh man that's cool
for them no this is cool for me
this is sort of like a gift to myself
because in what I do I've been in this
league for 18 years
the season nine months long there's no
such thing as the weekends and my homies
that I grew up with they all got
families they're back home like they
work so my brother will go home every
now and then they all get to spend time
together so this is the one time we get
time together
so because they know you from way back
they're not afraid like they see it yeah
any and everything and so this the thing
too the life that I Live Now is a very
abnormal life
so it's so cool to share this abnormal
stuff with the people who
you know I grew up with who see this
stuff and be like hey man what are you
what is that what is that yeah so for
the last I don't know 12 years I'd
always be like yo fellas y'all ready we
going on a trip where y'all want to go
where y'all want to go I'll be like man
let's let's go out there let's go to
Greece let's go to Spain guess where
they want to go every year
Cabo Vegas Vegas yeah every single year
Las Vegas imagination and so a couple of
my homies didn't have passports so this
year I made them get passports and I
said we'll go to Vegas but we're going
somewhere after that and when I tell you
those five days were five of the best
days I didn't had in a long time because
you literally just laughed like I
laughed the entire time and there's a
realness about it that I appreciate yeah
um it's really good to hear that because
I think you know what you hear and even
especially in this town it's filled with
people who are very successful who
you know came from a variety of
backgrounds but it's not it's not
unusual for somebody to have kind of
risen through quite a few obstacles
because that's sort of the engine you
know that drives them and makes them
successful and then they become very
successful and then they have kids and
then they're pissed off because they
can't figure out how to motivate their
kids because their kids are living a
life of privilege and I know this is
something you spend a lot of time
thinking about and and trying to figure
out how to you know kind of work against
um because the book is as much as it's
about mentorship and family and and work
ethic it's it's it's about parenting too
it's about you thinking about how can I
make sure that my kids kind of
understand the principles that are
important to me that I think were uh You
Know instrumental in My Success how do I
instill that in these young people who
are living this insane life that is just
you know very few people
um get to experience
it's a it's a daily daily battle and
it's something that I don't say battle
now this is a a good problem to have but
the people that I literally look up to
and confide in and stuff like that I'm
always asking questions of how
I'll ask somebody with the quickness how
can I be a better dad before I can be a
better basketball player that is the one
thing I'm always just asking questions
oh that's a cool tradition that's a cool
tradition because like we just said
those are the things that you get a
chance to see if they stand to tell the
time and
I appreciate that uh with my parents
yeah I mean you took you took your kids
back to the the back to um North
Carolina to you know what used to be the
filling station I mean maybe just you
know tell people who you're who your
grandfather was and and why it's so
important and and why it was important
to you to bring your kids back there and
help them to understand you know who
this person was yeah so my my
grandfather uh his name is no thank
Nathaniel Jones uh Nathaniel Frederick
Jones he was one of 11 kids and actually
happened to be the sixth child the
middle child
and he had the first black owned service
station in North Carolina and I always
talk about it when you hear ownership
now I think you think of other people
working
right but for him that meant that he he
worked every single day
and getting a chance to take my kids
back
um was so fulfilling and the thing is is
my kids have been back and they go to
North Carolina all the time but there's
a certain age that your kids finally get
to where you talk to them differently
right it's not like just hey we're at
the service station try to remember this
yeah you know my kids were at the age at
that point in the book where
they knew they had heard about this
service station but they would remember
what they were seeing
and it's like we just talked about
you
you work so hard to
make sure your kids
have this or have that
and then what's crazy is you start to
like raise them and you realize how much
they need
what you was trying to make better for
them if that makes sense
yeah and it's hard to reverse engineer
it you don't want your kids to have to
endure difficult things uh and yet there
are lessons in those challenges that are
that are Priceless right but is there a
more graceful way to introduce those
Concepts and and have them be meaningful
to your kids without the the kind of
suffering aspect of it right like I
don't know you know I guess you're
you're running that experiment right now
always running that experiment always
open to uh to suggestions is
is just totally different and not saying
everything's different in a in a bad way
I grew up where I had to cut the grass
right I had to cut the grass uh we have
turf you know what I mean like we have
turf at our house so always just trying
to figure out different ways to
um
make sure
it's just understand the work you know
like we joke about it now me and my
brother about how my mom would be home
on her way home from work and one of us
had to wash the clothes and the other
one had to fold the clothes right there
was an anxiety about that that we were
like nervous and scared about like if my
dad was on his way home and we hadn't
cut the grass yet we're like oh my God
oh my God you know but that sort of
teaches you about procrastinating
teaches you about consequences if
different things don't happen
and
it's necessary
we're brought to you today by Roca
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code Rich Roll at roca.com or
you can click the link in the
description below okay back to the show
what was it about your grandfather that
made him such an indelible figure in
your life I mean obviously you know
first
black owned service station in North
Carolina like successful you talk about
it how he always had kind of a wad of
cash and it was important for him to
kind of be seen having that giving it
out being of service to the community
and being this you know he was very it
seemed like he was very aware
that he was
um
serving as this example of of success
for you know the younger people in the
community at large you know what's funny
about Deborah is that
we knew he had that water money in his
front pocket but I don't think everybody
else knew I think we knew because that
was our Papa you know what I mean like
if we went up and wanted something
depending on what it was my ice cream or
something we knew that or because we
were we was around him a lot more than
other people but I don't think people
knowingly knew that he had that lot of
money but
like we grew up as Mr Jones grandkids
right like that's what everybody knew it
says so anytime we went somewhere or we
was out in the city or whatnot because
my grand you very rarely actually seen
him in regular clothes I'm trying to
picture because
I got this video on my phone of my
granddad from his 60th birthday party
that we just found like a month ago
uh it's like a VHS tape wow my dad
I'll tell you this real quick my dad
taped everything when we were kids every
game
um when we would have like a family
function
there would be a camera sitting at the
family function just like that wow the
whole time so my dad maybe like a month
ago he took a bunch of the VHS tapes and
had them converted into DVDs sent them
out to Phoenix I mean when we finished
I'll show it to you on my phone and so
I'm watching so the first DVD I put in
is one of my high school games and so
I'm watching my high school game that's
cool and so then I pop another one in
and I see that it's like a party going
on and so I'm watching it and I'm like
man what party is this because we used
to have events all the time
and so then
I see my grandfather walk in and I got
like chills
and I'm watching it and I'm watching it
and then I actually pulled out my phone
and started recording it like whatever's
happening
and my Granddad comes in and then I see
on the wall that says like because
everybody said surprise right it was my
grandfather's 60th birthday
right it was his 60th birthday and I'm
trying not to get a emotional talking
about it but um
I took this video and I put it in my
family group chat with my mom my aunt my
wife my brother my two little cousins
and
my mom called me like crying immediately
and then me and my wife had been
together since I was 18. I didn't
realize my wife has never heard my
grandfather's voice
my kids had never heard my grandfather's
voice
um my mom said she hadn't heard his
voice since he had died
and this is when it really like set in
to me like how how crazy it was
so everybody's giving these speeches at
his 60th birthday mind you died when he
was 61. my brother so anytime you look
at a video or old video what you gonna
look for
probably gonna look for you yeah right
so I'm looking at the video and I'm
looking and I'm like dang where am I
where am I I'm like I probably brought
Papa to surprising because I always was
with him so I'm looking for me in the
video
my brother starts giving a speech to my
granddad and during my granddad speak
during the speech my brother says um
and I know Chris would say this if he
was here
so that now I realize I'm not there
um so I called my mom and I said mom Mom
where was I where was I and she said
what month it was and she said she was
probably at an AAU Tournament
right playing travel basketball and
that's when it hit me and at the time I
was watching this video while I was uh
in Arizona where I lived without my my
wife and my kids for the last four years
and uh that's when it hit me that
majority of my life I've been missing
things
you know like just constantly missing
things and striving to be like the best
player that you can be
and
man
this ain't supposed to be this kind of
podcast
it's all right man I mean
That's Heavy you know that's real but I
think it's clear that
you were a very important figure in in
his life as well and you showed up for
him and you meant a great deal to him
and he certainly understood that and
knew that
and he was just so you weren't there on
that one day but you know birthdays
whatever like on the daily
you were there for that guy you know
yeah for sure but um it just started me
realizing it started making me realize
how
I mean I wasn't there on that day but
my kids have had so many things now at
this point because I am a professional
athlete and I'm constantly traveling and
um
yes I'm working the provider what not
but it's still hard not being there yeah
for my kids there's a cost of greatness
if you want to be the best like that's
you know that is the the truth there are
sacrifices and there is a dark
underbelly and you know I kind of
appreciate you being honest about that
because people like to talk about here's
what it takes and are you willing and
it's like well what's on the other side
of that and where do your other values
come into play that get eroded for the
sake of of that Pursuit and I think it's
important to really ask yourself like is
that worth it or is everything else
properly in balance and if not like how
do you correct that that's why like the
first question I had for you is like you
know when these things come into
conflict like the people pleasing and
the and the obligations that you have
like you know there's a lot going on in
your life it would be impossible for
every bucket to be you know in absolute
balance on on every single day and
that's that's got to be hard and it must
be
I would suspect that it's it's lonely
because you can't really complain about
that like who are you going to talk to I
mean you can call LeBron and talk to him
about it but there are very many people
that you can have that conversation with
it's crazy you say that because uh me
Lebron Carmelo and D way right the the
banana boat crew or whatnot in the
relationship that that we had
um
it was sort of founded on that right I
got all my homies that I grew up with I
got my brother who was my right hand man
I got my family my wife and all that but
our relationship
and our closeness was built off the fact
that there were certain things that we
only
could talk about to each other
you know there are certain experiences
that only we could talk about to each
other I mean when Braun was thinking
about leaving Cleveland to go to Miami
he had his circle of friends that he was
talking to but when me and him talked it
was just always a different perspective
because I play and I know what he sort
of was going through and what he felt
like so you're exactly right it's it's
hard it's hard and you always sort of
battle with this am I being selfish
that's why I was asking you two like
what's the training like because
I mean for me
even now I'm out of season and I'm back
home right my family's here in La while
I'm in Phoenix so then when the season's
over
I'm right back yeah as soon as I got
back that next morning I was taking my
kids to school you know and trying to be
a present father as much as possible and
then still
training right yeah still trying to be
the best athlete that
you can be do you feel like
whatever you're fully invested in one
thing whether it's training practice
uh or showing up as a dad that
um you're feeling like you're falling
short or you should be doing the other
thing that's not getting attended to or
are you able to kind of like switch
those gears and and find a way to just
be like listen this is where my
attention is now I'm giving everything I
have to this
it's not perfect but
um but you know I'm cool with that and
I've made peace with that or do you
haunt yourself with I try to switch
gears pretty well sometimes I haunt
myself some days are better than others
there's some times where I am somewhere
with my kids and it's like put your
phone down and then there's some things
that it's like okay I'm trying to figure
out what team I'm going to like I can't
at this time yeah you know and it's a
battle you know and I think the one of
the biggest things that I try to do is
to really talk to my kids right like
really talk to my kids and be like
what's up what y'all think you know what
I mean like
um sometimes when I'm out with them so I
want to ask for a picture I'll do it
sometimes I'll be like no let me give
you know sometimes I want my kids to
hear
make sure they hear me telling someone
else that it's all about them you know
because our kids are at an age where
they're nobody's dummies they understand
any and everything that's going on but I
tell you the the really important person
too is my wife
right it's those conversations with her
and I mean I'm going through a lot of
stuff right now and you think about it
be very honest with you this summer
especially the fact that I'm away from
my family for all those months
during the summer my wife's trying to
plan vacation where we going here we're
doing this so we're doing that and I I
literally called my wife the other day I
was like look babe I know we want to
travel we want to do this stuff but
understand that I want to do and
experience all those things but
I gotta get to work right I got to get
to work I got to figure out where I'm
going to be and
I don't want that to hold my wife or my
kids back from traveling or experiencing
a vacation like these are real
conversations like that
and I'm and I meant it you know I want
to go here and go be there and do that
but it's it's so hard and and she was
like okay
I got it and that's when somebody knows
you like she knows that I want nothing
more than to do these experiences with
them but
the way that I'm programmed in
I gotta get to work yeah well you're
you're in this you know unique flux
situation right now right it's gonna get
sorted out pretty soon but right now
it's got to be
leaving you feeling like you're just not
sure which way everything is gonna yeah
and and for me
um I mean
I feel like I know every Nuance of this
league and how things work and all of
this after 18 years experience so
whatever situation it is whatever team I
just always ask them to you know be up
front and honest with me and communicate
with me as I do with them you know so
um having been in the league so long
like how is it different now at 30
you're 38 right 38 38 versus
28. obviously
um you know you're you're you're aging
up and that means you got to be paying
more attention to your training to your
recovery to your nutrition
um how does like longevity play into
your daily equation about how you kind
of approach your craft and how has that
changed or evolved like you just can't
get away with [__] now that you used to
be able to like not think twice about
right right but I'm I'm
JJ JJ Redick talked about it on his
podcast might have been one of the first
times he ever did his podcast when I was
with the Clippers with JJ
but it was like
I kind of got like a case of like OCD
right in that
I don't know like if somebody say
this is the type of water that you
should be drinking right like you need
to drink this water then
I won't drink any other type of water
I will figure out a way somehow some way
to make sure I have that with me every
time I go somewhere right so when it
comes to has it always been that way
though
uh I mean it was Sprite for a while
right right oh yeah so it hasn't always
been dialed in oh no it wasn't always
dialed in I'll tell you when I got to
the Clippers in 2011 was the first time
I'd ever been with a team that had a
team chef and a nutritionist
I played six years in the NBA before I
ever heard of a nutritionist yeah John
uh John Salley all the time man he's
he's a couple times yeah he's like he's
like he wouldn't believe what people are
eating and how uh there's just this
insane lack of Education I mean I'm sure
it's different now or I hope it is
really still never had a chef team Chef
never had a nutritionist until I got to
the Clippers I get to the Clippers right
going from New Orleans to L.A
and the team nutritionist tells me about
Elite Test
right you know what that is I don't know
food sensitivity test okay never heard
of this she tells me that I'm gonna go
give my blood
and they're going to take my blood and
they're going to test it against 100 or
something different ingredients and tell
me
what it what it means so go get my blood
have to wait a few weeks I get this
sheet of paper back and it's got Reds
yellows and greens right so anything
that was green meant that
uh I can eat right anything that was
yellow or red I had to cut from my diet
this is what I was being told and it had
different things on there it said this
makes you more sleepy uh
this makes you more tired all of this
different type of stuff and what was
crazy was at the time like me Blake and
DJ all of us had done it in like I think
one year Blake said
chicken he couldn't have chicken so we
would get on the plane and like be
pushing chicken over to him like you
sure you don't want this you sure but
the very first time I ever did it I had
27 Reds and yellows 27 reds and yellow
and when I came into the NBA
my every pre-game meal of mine you know
what it was it was salmon salmon rice
and something green I felt like that was
sounds that sounds on the healthy side
of things yeah yeah absolutely that's
what I had every before every game when
my results came back it said something
like I think salmon was red on there it
had like hops was red so that was it for
Corona that was it for all these
different things I was stressed out I
was like what am I gonna eat
but
you think this is what you got to do to
be
yeah you know really good so so you do
that do you feel the difference what
else was off the table oh I have to go
on my email and check or whatnot but it
was a lot of stuff that was off the
table that's the first time you ever
thought about diet or making changes or
trying to you know kind of yeah follow
directions yeah because when I was
younger in New Orleans I eat whatever
didn't matter didn't matter whatever
like there's a difference between a chef
and a cook too
you know so everything that I was eating
back then I mean I ate sweet tea I mean
I drank sweet tea with every meal I used
to
hey what else Krispy Kreme Donuts I used
to have Little Debbie's uh uh oatmeal
cream pies
you know and my wife at the time she was
doing the shopping and I used to you
know simply lemonade yeah like the
lemonade oh I could drink one of them by
myself it's just all sugar nothing but
sugar but I didn't know what you don't
know like you don't know and so then
Fast Track I'm playing
playing you know still don't really know
much I'm I'm doing that leap test every
year and it's changing a little bit some
of the foods would change I would get
down to my first year in Houston when I
did the test I think I had
three Reds and yellows right so I guess
what that mean that my body was sort of
you're getting better at it yeah so boom
is when um
uh executive produced game changers how
did that happen how did that come about
so it came about through uh Ethan
Ethan Ethan brown right she already had
a beyond meat like partnership before
that so this is the thing I didn't have
a partnership at the time so uh Beth uh
moscowers that worked with Beyond Beth
we knew Beth from Sports and basketball
so I was playing in Houston
um Beth sent out some beyond meat for my
chef to try
mind you I I don't know this I ain't
really heard of it like that so after
one of the games I come home and my Chef
makes beyond meat
after a game right he tells us to eat it
his burgers and stuff and I ate the food
and I remember sitting there like
well damn I'm I don't feel like heavy
right like because
say what you want to I played a long
time in this league I know what my body
feel like right I know my body better
than just about anything so
I didn't know but so much about beyond
meat at the time right but then we tried
it again tried it again so at that time
um
Ethan asked me about
um Game Changer so I saw early sort of
clip of Game Changers or whatnot and I
was looking at it and was like oh yeah I
would love to to be a part of this
man
I
like seen some of the athletes in it and
I'm one of those people I know like
y'all but I'm very curious I can't take
somebody else's word for it I gotta try
it myself
so I went so that was it you saw like an
early cut yeah and you got interested in
what that might be like for yourself and
just took the leap yep just flick the
switch yep because I'm wondering where
people too to where like I never forget
everybody in my house was about to watch
um
what was that
the like documentary like scare you from
eat meat was it uh uh
um not not what the health you mean yeah
what the health yeah what the health
right so they started watching it one
day in my house and I looked at the
beginning and I said oh can't watch it
can't watch it I walked away I wouldn't
watch it because I'm one of those people
that if I see it it's gone
make me you know I mean not not
necessarily eat stuff
so
I did it I went cold turkey or cold so
interesting I always thought I didn't
know that story I always thought like
you were you had gone plant-based and
had experienced benefits and as a result
of that and then kind of talking about
it that's how you found your way to the
movie no so Ethan yeah Ethan was how I
found my way to the movie and I'm
telling you
I was like hold up man I'm seeing some
of these athletes talk about it or
whatnot and like I said I had had 14
years of playing games and waking up and
being sore right aching and I got to the
point
where
sometimes I wouldn't like like play with
my kids right like the day before a game
if my kids wanted to be out in the yard
like throwing baseball or running around
playing I'd be like no I gotta stay off
my feet I gotta stay off my feet and so
if not for Ethan and Beth and all them I
would have never
ever that's interesting so so what was
the uh experience like jumping in going
completely plant-based after having kind
of no experience with that like what did
you like did you feel better did you see
the results
yeah exactly how how it went so I just
got back from Family Vacation
it was like a Sunday and I remember I
was telling my chef
or not because it's during the summer
too so
of course everybody always says it's a
lot easier if you got a chef but
this is out of season so I had a chef a
few days but here in La I just sort of
had to figure it out you get to know
Veggie Grill really really good yeah
especially when you don't know like the
foods that right you could just go to
Veggie Grill and just eat you know
French fries and exactly you can eat
like [__] there exactly yeah but like I
said you don't know so
the amount of foods that I eat now that
I never used to eat it's crazy and I
tell people who even think about going
plant-based or doing certain things is
that I'm what four years in and I'm
still learning I'm still learning so the
education aspect is huge and if we find
a way to educate kids earlier then yeah
look at what it would look like so for
me what happened
oh man first of all I remember sitting
on the couch like sitting there like I
felt like I was on drugs like I was
tripping like sitting there like oh man
what am I gonna do what am I gonna do
right because you're like what am I
gonna eat yeah
but then my body so this is what started
happening
and I I gotta believe everybody's story
is different but my nose started running
like just
I would be chilling sitting there
chilling and my nose would just start
running right because I used to also
like follow and listen to a lot of stuff
that Dr sebi would say right and I used
to hear him say the stuff about mucus
and all this stuff man I was like what's
going on and I used to I used to get
science when I was a kid I had
was it five sets of tubes in my ears
like sinus infections and I used to get
sick like clockwork like twice a year
during the season
and I used to make this sound let me see
let me see I used to do that like all
day which was like just mucus yeah man
it was like the mucus was leaving my
body
right and I know it sounds so dramatic
or whatnot but that's that's what I felt
then
I started going to the bathroom
obviously a lot more regular
that
changed like that and then
um I was training I just started back
training maybe three four days in I was
like training hard to get ready for the
season
I called my my trainer and I was like I
was like Donnie I was like are we not
going that hard right now or something
like I'm not like aching he was like no
we're getting after it
I stopped having to put ice on my knees
every every single day
and inflammation down
recovery faster I used to have guns no
no like impairment of your performance
though if anything no yeah am I in my
gut my gut is what really changed so
there would be games that I played over
my career where I'd be like burping like
crazy or drinking stuff during the game
and just feeling bloated
you know and that that changed for me
and I had a few health issues gut wise
and whatnot that literally
changed
so four years you've been doing this
you still feel good yeah and you're
still learning you're not going to
Veggie girl every day no no but but I
hooked you up with Simon right yeah he
should be he should be dialing you up
pretty good man listen Simon was amazing
because for me at this point now it's
about the margins right so thank you so
much for putting me in contact with
Simon who took a look at
um my blood work and was like oh look
you could definitely stand to add some
iron
right yeah and I don't know if this is a
conversation for here but we might as
well have it you can choose whether to
use it or not but when I grew up I
thought creatine
was like
almost like a steroid right but it's not
correct it's not a steroid no I mean
it's it's pretty effective in in helping
you build uh lean muscle mass but you
also end up retaining a lot of water
water yeah right right I remember that's
what he said so I was trying to do like
five grams or something like that but
even when I heard creatine it was like
huh what no we can't take that you know
so it's an education aspect to a lot of
this stuff that you just don't know and
so what is the like the meals look like
these days oh I eat a lot of mushrooms
uh-huh I eat a lot of mushrooms
um a lot of lentils yep
depends on what it is I I mean
I have I have like just egg I think that
was one of the big things was that you
start finding out so let me just tell
you we're on a road trip and you'll see
like a spread of food for our team right
for breakfast before we go to practice
and it's so funny because
um
probably most teams don't have vegan
options yeah but I've had a couple
teammates that like went plant-based let
me say that right plant-based options
um the funniest thing to me is when I
come into a hotel and I see the
plant-based pancakes and regular
pancakes the easiest way to make me mad
is to see the plant-based pancake
sitting over here and they purple
right all right because a lot of people
don't know just make them the way that
people like to eat them it doesn't it's
not a huge leap to make it taste
basically the same
listen
the only thing that is missing is
egg yeah or butter or something like
that right like you cannot tell me that
somebody can tell the difference between
Earth Balance and regular butter
it's pretty close right really close
really close and so
I mean I could have guys over my house
all the time and they could eat a whole
meal and would have no clue that it was
plant-based but at some point you got to
figure out a way to start making it just
food right instead of every time saying
oh this is the plant-based food yeah and
you don't feel like it's it's impinging
your ability to perform or to you know
stay strong in the gym and you know move
quickly agility all that kind of stuff
do you feel like it's helping you like
you've been doing this for four years
now obviously you know I would assume
that you you're feeling like this is an
advantage yeah I definitely feel like
it's an advantage I feel like I'm always
trying to just learn a little bit more
yeah you know just always just trying to
you know make sure you're getting that
protein intake make sure you're getting
all these different things but it's it's
just like anything else you plan yeah
you playing we go on a road trip I plan
out and how does that work with with
your teammates are they giving you [__]
or some of them on board I've had a few
teammates who have went completely
plant-based uh Jay Crowder my first year
when I was with the sons we were in the
locker room and after the game they all
all my teammates were sitting there with
ice on their knees and Jay was like we
called 99 he was like yo see why why you
ain't never got ice on your knees like
like everybody else I was like I mean I
sometimes when I need to but I don't
need to next thing you know during
All-Star break he went plant-based right
yeah had a teammate of mine uh Tori
Craig who
last year he used to be talking about
like how much his knees hurt and aching
and all that he hit me last summer and
told me he was going plant-based and I
think he shot the best percentage he
shot in a while this season because he
wasn't
he was back dunking again and doing all
these different things so
yeah to each his own or not but I know
I'm gonna do what I got what I gotta do
for me it's working for you I mean did
you know John Sally before this or did
you get to know him like after I knew I
knew John but I never knew like that
John had been plant-based and stuff like
that for a long time and it's crazy
because lady Carmen Wilson that works
with me
um she uh she used to work with the heat
when John played for Miami back in the
day it's wild yeah I find that
um
there's a receptivity to this uh in the
athlete that's kind of Aging up or
somebody who's dealt with a bunch of
injuries and is looking for an advantage
or just realizing they're in the
Twilight of their career and are kind of
open to new ideas you know anything that
might you know extend their career a
couple years longer and I think we're in
a really interesting
era right now in terms of athletic
performance I mean Novak just one is
23rd yeah Grand Slam you know Tom Brady
wins the Super Bowl 43 like 10 years ago
if you said that that something like
that could happen nobody would have
believed you so it's really cool to see
older athletes like pushing the
boundaries and and kind of eclipsing
what everybody thought was possible
um
and them being kind of examples for a
broader audience around
the importance of wellness and the fact
that like what you put in your body
actually does matter right like you know
would have thought you know what I I
tell people just all the time my initial
Journey on this started out
sports related right I wanted to be the
best athlete that I could be I don't I
wasn't purely altruistic no come on it
was definitely not yeah that's how it is
forever we're self-interested creatures
you know listen my my
my previous coach Monty Williams who is
just amazing and all the sayings he he
always says he says that we want to be a
team that's consistent right so if we're
playing against another team he always
says you just want to constantly be like
this against them right the whole game
because he says at some point they're
just not going to be able to handle that
right like somebody's just at some point
gonna be like man stop right so when I
talk about like
feeling well and and food and all this
stuff because people be like man what
you mean you know you don't you don't
want a chicken sandwich you really ain't
gonna eat no steak you you know that's
what people say to me and so for me
it is
I had 14 years of experience of waking
up after some of those hard fought games
and like just being
sluggish and aching and stuff and so for
me it's like if I know I can make
something stop
right then I'm gonna do what I gotta do
you know I mean regardless of how hard
it is or whatnot is it's been cool but
like I said it started out sports
related and then I started finding out
all the other health benefits and I
wanted to start sharing it with my
family because I grew up in the South
right where everything is fried like I
grew up eating chitlins fat back sweet
tea
everything and still when I go home this
is not
like yeah
no one talks about this stuff when they
go home so it was stressful for me at
first to go home and look at my
grandmother
and tell her that I wasn't gonna eat all
this good food that she just cooked
right they looking at me like who are
you right or you're you're rejecting
them I mean that's that's you know
you're it's it's all tied up in love and
that makes it very tricky exactly and
and the thing is is that
the education aspect of it which we're
we're missing and I try to make sure
that I get into these different
communities inner cities whatever it may
be because we also grow up with a lot of
our family with all these different
diseases
right these different diseases
um John Lewis uh who um we worked on a a
movie together called uh they're trying
to kill us right and it was just talking
about
where
like where
a lot of the education needs to be
taking place because I grew up with
family members with gout right everybody
got high blood pressure I don't know if
you've seen a thing while I was talking
to my dad my dad all of his brothers and
sisters take blood pressure medicine
you know and a lot of that is
this is me talking I'm like I said I'm
still learning but everyone always says
that this different disease is
hereditary and this is passed down well
I think part of it is but some of it is
the ingredient I mean the recipes that's
passed down yeah right from from
generation to generation and unless
someone's educated on it it's just going
to continue
it's one thing to kind of adopt a
certain way of eating like you have and
just say this is working for me this is
cool and it's another thing altogether
to say you know what like there's
something really powerful here and I
want to use this you know privilege that
I have in this platform to talk about it
and and perhaps you know change uh you
know change habits change make it make a
real social impact you know as a result
of this voice that I have and you know
John Lewis is my boy like I love that
guy and and we were all you know kind of
involved in the edit of of their trying
to kill you so you know so yeah I'm very
familiar with the movie and I think you
know that's the kind of movie that's
needed more than any of the other movies
because the people who are suffering the
most and could benefit the most from
just a little bit of education and
access are the ones that aren't getting
it right it is the you know the
underprivileged communities the food
deserts these areas
um that are kind of entrenched in a in a
cycle of poverty and disease and the
disease a result of Lifestyle all habits
and and you know diet
um that's so unnecessary and easily
rectified and I think the fact that you
lent your voice to that movie and so
many other you know really
um
you know interesting performers and
entertainers and athletes you know Etc
to time out to basically contribute to
that as well
um was a really powerful thing I wish
more people had seen that movie yeah
that's a whole other podcasting story
um yeah I mean I think what I what I
take from that like is
this idea that
um
that you you're aware of of your
position in life right and that that
comes with a certain level of
responsibility and there's an
intentionality
um that you have about okay how am I how
am I leveraging this position that I'm
in or how am I using my voice to you
know basically make the world a little
bit of a better place and and from my
not knowing you and like just kind of
observing you know how you've done that
it seems pretty clear to me that there's
a lot of thought that goes into that you
know what else too and I'd be lying if I
didn't say it there's a selfish aspect
that comes from it too and I'll say this
because
I love like my people and the people
around me you know so sometimes I might
put something in a group chat and
somebody might not like it or not but
just think about life right like life
and
I want not only myself but the people
around me to be around me as long as
possible and if you can help them in one
little way just
maybe add a little bit more longevity to
their life or be able to wake up without
a sickness or without aches and pains
you know then
there's not one person I think that I
probably met who has tried at least
plant-based for a little while and not
seen a change or not because we be in
our habits and routines for so long and
for so many years there's so many people
will be like no I'm just made this way
oh yeah I always just sort of like break
out like this or I such and such I I do
this but
the one thing that we all have in common
is people is what we eat what we take
care yeah but it's also a broader
observation and and conversation around
um habits and change and how do we
change and a belief in our ability to
like grow and evolve right if you're
just like well this is who I am and this
is how I do it and this is the way it's
always been you're in kind of a
regressive mind State as opposed to I'm
the person who who's trying new things
who's who understands the value of of of
um you know putting myself in
uncomfortable situations experimenting
Etc that's that's how you grow and you
have a belief and a and a lifetime of
experience practicing that but a lot of
people don't I need I need to take you
with me to a few people and but you tell
them that all right I don't think
they're gonna hear it
hear it the same for me where do you
want to go but no that's that's real and
it's so much I don't know which is why
like I said
um I was talking to Jess I was talking
to Jess and I was like Jess
we've been doing this now I've been
plant-based now for like four years and
this was last summer and I was like
there's got to be an expert I was like
I'm out here just sort of winging it
right figuring it out right on my own in
the city of 20 million people there's
got to be somebody who lives in La that
you know knows something about yeah it's
got it it's got to be somebody because
like I said like it's the margins right
like if somebody can be like hey have
you tried this have you tried this this
may get a little bit more energy here oh
if you tried this and so
um I was so grateful when she uh she
sent your info and I started watching
things and I was like oh this is what I
needed this is what I need and so
that sense of community and just your
willingness to even put us in contact
with Simon has been amazing that's cool
and for people that are listening we're
talking about Simon Hill front of the
podcast
um and you should listen to his podcast
if you're not on that because yeah he's
going deep he goes yeah yeah
um so beyond the the plant-based thing
like what are some of the other like
longevity enhancing you know career
extending sort of things that you
practice now that maybe you didn't used
to like
um I'm um
I do the cold tubs you do I have a cold
tub in my house are you on the Jesse
plunge sauna situation yeah he he Jesse
is OD with it but I got it I got an
infrared sauna so at my house right
outside my bedroom in Phoenix is a is a
cold plunge right right so I'll get in
sometimes right when I get in the
morning yeah sometimes I do it right
when I get up in the morning A lot of
times I do it later in the afternoon or
whatnot I get in three minutes five
minutes I'll do the infrared sauna uh I
actually just got a cold plunge here at
my house in La probably like a week and
a half ago because my son we finished
working out the other night he was like
Dad can I get in the plunge I was like
absolutely
absolutely yeah do you do that uh Plunge
in the sauna together or you do those
things separately it depends on what day
it is sometimes I'll do them together
yep and after the plunge do you get in
the there's the idea that like you
should never do the sauna after the the
plunge you want to end on the cold end
on the cold yeah do you do that or no so
it's funny like
if I'm going to bed you know what I mean
a lot of times I do the sauna before bed
it's sort of helped me sleep a little
better or whatnot at least my oil rings
yeah I know so I was thinking I was like
that's an aura right yeah yeah
um because that sleep stuff is so
important and that's the hardest thing
for me to do get a good night's sleep
yep
wow you think when you're training like
that that shouldn't be an issue hardest
thing for me to do is sleep and
uh because your mind is going nuts got a
few reasons
um I think one of them is like I said I
do live in Phoenix by myself so maybe
it's this subconscious of like the worry
of my family you know my wife and my
kids
um
the other is just sort of the time
schedule that we're on and I tell you so
the way it works
is I'll play a game
let's say I play a game in L.A and then
the game might start start at 7 30.
game gets over 10 30 11 whatnot and we
get on the bus drive to the airport go
to LAX
say we got a back-to-back plan in Utah
the next night
our plane might not take off from LAX
depending on what's going on the weather
or how the bags or if a guy's late to
the plane we might not take off till
midnight right
say we don't get into Utah to the hotel
till
two two two
thirty a.m now our game is at 7 pm
we're all jacked up boom so now I just
played this game I'm wired I'm up like
yeah you can't just shut that off and go
to sleep and then guess what usually
we'll have team meeting at 11 10 or 11
A.M we might not have been to bed till
four
right four or five o'clock right you
know so it's this complete cycle and
that's not in isolation that's on the
heels of weeks and weeks of that exactly
yeah exactly so I'm not complaining by
no means but sleep like that's when you
really recover so how do you how
obviously the aura gives you the stages
in your HRV and all that kind of stuff
but like what other than like cold
plunge and sauna what are some other
sleep hygiene things that have been
beneficial
man um
you do like the the the
um like the neural beats and the face
mask and you know that kind of stuff or
yeah no I I I I I not eating too late at
night yeah yeah I try not to eat too
late at night
with that huh I'm bad about that yeah I
know but that also too just like for for
weight management and all that stuff too
is try not to eat too late I just
I don't know is is can you nap yes I can
do that yeah I can definitely do that
all my friends and my family they say
I'm narcoleptic because I I will fall
asleep with the quickness as soon as I
get home from practice usually I sit
down and cat but that's good I'm not
like a go lay in the bed and I'm gonna
take a nap right yeah it usually just
happens I'll get home from practice and
maybe I'm getting my body work my tissue
work and just fall asleep there so I'm
definitely a napper what does the body
work look like like what kind of
what are you doing
a lot of times it's Active Release
um not a lot of cupping uh
uh I have and Shelly like they're
different
um and actually like uses her her feet
you know I mean like she sits in a chair
and sort of like mashes yeah and whatnot
and then she'll like get her hands and
my calf muscles and feet and all that
stuff Shelly's more you're on the table
and and working on you and then we got
team people to work on it sometimes too
but that's a that's an everyday thing
just about anything else that you've
like learned that's you think is like
giving you an advantage that you think
uh other athletes or particularly like
athletes who are starting to age up a
little bit I lift a lot I do yeah I lift
a lot during the season like how does
that work when you are traveling so much
and it's just about game game game left
left yeah the older I've gotten the more
that I realize the day of games yes
really yes day again left
um so think about this right and someone
said this to me a while ago our season
is so long so if if you think that
you're just going to lift heavy during
the summer and then just cruise for nine
months you can't do that yeah you can't
do that and so for me but you want to be
on point for the game too you don't want
to be
fatigued
yeah like if you do it enough over and
over and over again like not gonna be
fatigued right but I I left it's like
maintenance lifting exactly yeah exactly
like if we got two days between games
maybe it's a little heavier like
depending on what my output was in that
game but I'm I'm not shooting basketball
I'm not playing a game without without
lifting
what do you what do you wish you you
knew when you were in your early years
or the years that you know now
I always say to one thing I wish I could
change in my career right is not a win
or a loss it was when I
two of my meniscus back in 2009 2010 is
that I took my rehab more serious
I was so young
um two of my meniscus had surgery
their rehab sort of whatever but I was
so young I was like I'm gonna be right
back you just rushed it rushed it too
much to get back what happened to was
towards the end of the season I came off
a ball screen and I knocked knees with a
guy and so back in the old NBA no
offense to the old NBA but everything
was just icing stem
right everything anytime you got hurt
they would just put some stem on it and
put a little ice on there and see what
happens
so I remember I knocked knees and I was
the same knee I had meniscus surgery on
so after I knocked knees I team trainer
we had like four games left in the
season they was like we shut you down
for the season he was like don't do
nothing he was like don't do nothing for
like the next week or two or whatnot
just stay off of it as a young kid that
don't know nothing about nothing if you
tell me to stay off of it what I'm gonna
do
I'ma stay off I'm not going to train I'm
not gonna do nothing
season ended and then I had to do a
Jordan commercial I had to do a shoe
commercial at the arena
and I remember showing up for the
commercial and when they got ready to
tell me like to do something basketball
wise
I couldn't I couldn't move yeah like I
couldn't move and I looked down at my
leg and my left leg was so much smaller
in my right leg it had atrophied
all right yeah because like I didn't
know like I was fine walking up and down
steps but I ended up having to go to DC
the entire summer and rehab and over
again
and it's like
um
like the training aspect of it is what I
wish I knew
earlier right like the little nuances of
lifting the right way and the training
like that that is what I wish all the
off Court uh protocols maintenance
strength functional strength well it's
one thing knowing it but it's one thing
doing it the right way right like I
could show you how to do a squat but you
might be
using all quads right your hamstrings
might be shut off you you might not be
using your glutes you might you know
what I'm saying so like it goes back to
like I said the details how is the
league kind of changed or maybe it
hasn't changed in terms of how it thinks
about
um
you know the wellness of the players
long term you know you you mentioned
like oh the Clippers had a nutritionist
like do all the teams have that now are
they paying more attention to that kind
of stuff yeah so when I played in
Houston for the Rockets we had
um we had a chef
right it was uh it was one guy who was
amazing but everybody coming in there
like no offense to him because it was
just him right so if you order something
on Monday or whatnot when you came in on
Tuesday if you wanted something
different
he had probably already had
what you had on Monday May ready to give
to you you know what I'm saying which is
tough right which is tough on him and
it's it's amazing to see how these teams
and organizations have changed now that
like in Phoenix we got like five six
chefs maybe more like there's a whole
kitchen that's cool I remember when I
went and seen the Hawks practice
facility years ago they got a whole
Training Table there's so much and it's
important
yeah you know I think teams started
realizing like it's so important that
these guys are getting right because
when you at this level of training not
just what you're putting into your body
but the timing of it right so like right
after practice you know you got a window
of when you need to get these nutrients
and all that stuff into your body so
yeah
um that's great to hear but also it's
still on you to shoulder the
responsibility for you know going that
extra mile and I'm thinking about like
all the stories you hear about LeBron
and how he you know devotes a not
insignificant you know portion of his
salary to taking care of his body and
the people that he surrounds himself
with with to like you know really make
sure that he's operating at his best and
I'm curious whether you know you've
learned from him and kind of how he's
pushed the envelope and you know where
he's willing to go with all that kind of
stuff and yeah whether he started I do
the same things you do the same you know
what I mean with all the
chefs uh
uh my team you know what I mean which is
a pretty significant team and it is a
pretty penny you know what I mean that
you spend on it but it's invaluable you
know I mean your body is your I mean
your your valuation is how you're
performing on the court right so
everything stems from that and if you're
not prioritizing that and making that
first everything else kind of yeah it's
a model's way right so my book tour is
coming up that I start in New York like
so when I when I go to to New York right
so when I travel of course my wife my
brother Carmen everyone who works with
me Jess will be there but guess what
my basketball trainer gonna be there I'm
gonna have somebody with me lifting and
I'm gonna have a
a masseuse a Bodywork person with me who
will travel with me so if I got to be at
a a podcast or something at eight we'll
probably start at five right right
because all of that is necessary yeah
you got to work that in you got to plan
ahead you got to prioritize all that
kind of stuff yeah yeah that's for real
man that's legit that's that's what
being a professional is oh one thousand
percent so like as soon as we finish
I'll get to my phone
um probably call my wife first but then
C was was for lunch yeah
um I want to talk about leadership for a
little bit
um you've held leadership positions uh
Players Association all the like
um
and uh you know this is something else
that that it appears you've learned
quite a bit from from your grandfather
other mentors that you've had how do you
think about like what are what are the
what are the things that make for a
great leader and how do you try to kind
of show up in your various
responsibilities to to lead in your own
way
I think the number one thing is
communication
communication so
in different situations some people
would be like man always talking always
talking I always say this
would you rather
someone tell you how they feel about you
or would you have to wonder how they
feel and somebody be talking about you
behind your back right like that's
that's the thing when it comes to
basketball or whatnot like if we out
there on the court and we're playing
do I need a guess if you want the ball
in a spot right because if we're on
teams I think that's the big part is
communicating
um
leadership is also understanding when
you got to delegate
and if I be perfectly honest with you is
that people don't understand this part
when it comes to leadership is that
sometimes it's going to sound crazy but
it's the truth
sometimes you gotta ask people for their
input
even if you really don't want it
if that makes sense not saying like ask
them
but not not like want to hear it like
say you're you're making a decision well
leadership is about consensus building
and getting a group to kind of all get
in get behind one certain idea and you
can't do that from a pure position of of
dictatorship no exactly and so what I'm
saying is even if you're trying to
decide between A and B right or say
you're trying to decide between a b and
c this is just being really honest so
you already got your heart set on that
you're going to do a
right you still need to go ask
because people feel totally different
when they feel like that they've had
some input on what's taking place right
now when you go ask these people
they may also agree with you that it's a
you know and a few of them might say b a
few of them might say c and a few might
say a but if you can learn to at least
collaborate
let people feel like they are a part of
the decision being made that if they do
feel like they are part of it sometimes
good bad or indifferent they will
embrace it totally different right and
really really go for it who taught you
that
experience yeah but basketball coaches
probably don't operate that way no not
always but it's a different kind of
leadership but the good coaches do
what's the difference between a good
coach and a not so good coach
oh sometimes it's luck
and then sometimes is
I mean if you if you're coaching an
elite player
right an elite player then not saying
the player isn't coachable or whatnot
but at least sometimes there should at
least be and it don't even have to be an
elite player just guys on your team
sometimes you should just ask them how
they feel about a coverage right you
talk about like people being invested
right like say you got a company say you
start this new code this new company
over here or whatnot and you're hiring
people those people that you initially
hired to begin at newco if you give them
more than just a salary and maybe some
percentage of the company how you think
they're gonna work in order to try to
build that company well if they have a
stake they have an equity stake and
ownership stake obviously they're going
to be more invested in success exactly
and so I remember when I played for the
Clippers uh and I pay attention to stuff
I remember
when Doc Rivers got the job he made sure
that because everybody used to always
try to say it was like me and Blake it's
me and Blake doc made sure that when he
came there it was me Blake and DJ
right and what he did was
we were out in Vegas for like training
camp and there was three vans right we
were staying at a hotel but practice
would be at UNLV he gave me a pair of
keys Blake a parakeets and DJ a
parakeets right because before doc got
there it was Chris and Blake Chris yeah
he wanted to give DJ some ownership
right and he gave DJ he said DJ you in
charge of the defense
right you are in charge of the defense
so that was an ownership and
responsibility yeah that's cool
um do you think about uh future
ownership for yourself absolutely yeah
what would that look like for you man in
the best case scenario because people
always talk to me about coaching right
and I coach my AAU program like the
young kids because they actually listen
I don't think NBA players gonna listen
too much so that's why I love coaching
coaching my hey I'll own the team I
don't want to coach these guys yeah yeah
sometimes we we don't listen as well but
also it's not just that it's because
I've had
such an opportunity to learn just about
every Nuance of what it takes in a team
right through CBA negotiations through
playing for this long to having
conversations with
um I mean well everything that happened
uh in the bubble right like put you like
in a really challenge challenging
situation where you had to show up in a
way that probably made you really had to
stretch right no no question and even
through like I said some of those CBA
negotiations like I got to know what's
eating really well right West is uh one
of the governor the governor of the
Milwaukee Bucks uh Stan cronky right
Stan is amazing I used to sit next to
Stan in those negotiations how many
teams does he own yeah right right Stan
and his son Josh too just genuine
incredible people you know they they got
the hockey team they got the Arsenal
um they have the Rams they got the
Nuggets but just genuine guys and a lot
of these people I've gotten to know I've
got to know Michael Rubin uh I know
Balmer from I know it should be in all
these different
um Governors around the league that I've
gotten to know
um and not saying all of them but
sometimes I talk to some of them just
give them advice right on just how to
approach us as players and treat us like
human beings you know what I'm saying
not saying that they don't but not just
as the product going on the court like
talk to us about the business of the
game right like hey guys this is why we
need to make the playoffs or whatnot
because this this and this right these
patches that we put on our jerseys now
you see them
that's on our game jerseys I think now
and on our practice uniforms
how much is that company paying to be on
our Jersey
you know so having these real
conversations are important and that's
why
um I want to be part of uh uh on a team
I can see it man I can see it in your
future I mean I think you you handle
everything during the the the pandemic
and the bubble situation with a lot of
Grace and dignity and that had to have
been really hard but you were able to
get Barack on the phone come on man
man you got that guy in your contacts
man he he's been unbelievable yeah I
tell you um
it's been situations that happen and
when you talk about somebody who's in a
thankless job or something like that who
uh
I'm trying to think
when that locker room situation happened
that time when I was in Houston we
played against the Clippers I talked to
uh
President Obama after that
and a number of times in different
situations and he just always
been been like you got to stay above to
pray right and so when somebody like
that tells you
that then
yeah you're gonna listen every time yeah
uh very valuable advice especially
you know in these times where
everybody's got a hot take and you know
everything that comes out of your mouth
is going to create a new cycle and
there's a million podcasts and all of
that there's just a lot of noise out
there right and there's a lot of
misstatements of facts that probably get
you agitated make you feel like you got
to jump in and correct the record all
the time listen let me tell you about
how you just said exactly because I'm
home with my family and things like this
a lot of times where
the tough thing with certain podcasts
and all this stuff now where everybody's
trying to get that hot take is that
that's what the algorithm that's how
they're going to get attention exactly
get on it you just say what everybody
already agrees with no one cares exactly
the incentives are all [__] up and
it's so crazy because now it makes it
even hard to have real interactions with
people or something like that and
because you like man we talk about this
you gonna be on the podcast talking
about it
to tomorrow you know and so it's
it's crazy how things work because like
you said you just I'm just not the
person who's gonna run in and say man
that's not how this happened that's not
how to happen because a lot of times
you're actually doing something you're
doing the work sure but you also don't
want to be the guy who can't fall asleep
at night because you're in your mind
you're you're pissed off about something
you've read about yourself that wasn't
right and you feel neutered you know
because you want to correct the record
but you know it's not the right thing to
do like that [__] will drive you crazy
you know it's like how do you turn that
off that's so crazy you say that because
I I keep telling my family I'm at this
point now where I'm like
um because people at some point start
taking your kindness for weakness right
so I mean on a period I said a few
things here and there but it's it's a
lot of a lot of things what's going to
get clipped yeah there was a there were
some articles written about that what
you said on that podcast was it a couple
well you thought you talked about the um
I think you talked about uh leaving New
Orleans for the first time oh yeah yeah
see I just went so long without
saying anything but just like anybody
I'm I'm human like anybody at a certain
point you're like okay man enough is
enough all right and for me I've been in
so many situations where people really
don't have a clue of how a particular
situation went down
and I just always be like all right all
right and so
um I try to be cool as much as possible
and I pick and choose when I'm a
Make Your Move yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well call up a rock first run it by
him
um you you were talking about we talked
about your kids they play sports and
you're super active in Youth Sports
you've got you know you've got your own
AAU team
um
and I'm interested in kind of like your
philosophy around you Sports I mean
you're somebody who your grinder you're
a hard worker your dad used to tape up
your strong arm and you know make you
dribble with your weak aren't like work
your weaknesses all of that like maybe
not a task master but you were no
stranger to like the grind
um
how do you think about the best way for
young people to kind of engage with
sports so that they fall in love with it
while also learning how to become
performers like I'm just thinking about
a I had Malcolm Gladwell on the podcast
we had a long conversation about this
and his argument was that we kind of
have it upside down like the real focus
should be on getting young people to
just fall in love with sports and
movement so that they're setting
themselves up for a lifetime because
only .001 of these kids are going to
ever end up making a career out of it
but you know when they're 40 if they're
still you know really enjoying uh you
know basketball running whatever it is
tennis Etc
um they're gonna you know they're gonna
be healthier and happier so you as
somebody who's put a lot of time and
energy and thought and parenting into
this like how do you see that
well I think that's the goal the goal is
to
I know for me with my kids
and through our AAU program because we
know that every kid is not going to make
it to the NBA you know what we do have
is everyone every kid that's came
through our AAU program has gotten a
scholarship it's got a full scholarship
to go to college wow now we have 12 kids
that's a solid stat oh man it's every
kid has gone through your program has
gotten a college scholarship yep
everything is awesome because we we have
a standard obviously and my my parents
my mom books every flight hotel right
for all my Au kids and my dad you know
all the coaches are guys that
for the most part of guys that I grew up
with or not but the goal is to give them
an opportunity
right because when you play AAU Sports
there's a commitment there you got
practice you got certain weekends that
you have to commit to a team now with my
kids
my parents only let me and my brother
play two sports growing up
we play one year of three Sports I
played t-ball I play basketball and I
play football after that year my parents
said it's too expensive and too much
time we can't get you to everything they
made us choose two and my kids right
my daughter this past year thank God for
her she did everything
I remember I got out of practice one day
and my wife was like cam has a
volleyball game today I was like when
did she get on the volleyball team I've
never seen her with a volleyball in her
hand ever in my life so my daughter she
played soccer she plays basketball she
plays softball and she played volleyball
my son just plays basketball I hate it
you know he knows I played soccer for a
little bit he did for a little bit but
then he stopped and now he just wants to
play basketball now I I tell them this
and this is what sport has done for me
sport has taught me everything in life
taught me everything in life it's taught
me about sacrifice is taught me about
hard work it's taught me about pain
right like heartache all these different
things sport has taught me and
that's the thing with my kids is that
I want them to like you said if they
fall in love with it like you really
care about something when I wake up in
the morning and I know I'm hooping or
it's a game day that's a there's a love
about that
I've I've never woken up like I mean I
have bad days just like anybody else but
genuinely loving something
right like I do like the game of
basketball I think everybody should have
that you can't will that in another
person that has to come from within that
person themselves right yep
yep did your boy have that for
basketball my son you know what he loves
it and it's it's crazy because
he'll watch clips of it as soon as he
get up in the morning he come to YouTube
and he watching clips of other people
playing all the time all the time now
the question is
what kind of love do you have for it
like
you might just love to watch it and
that's fine too but he plays and so as a
parent when you show up somewhere and
you see like you just want to know that
they're going their hardest right or
giving giving their best and knowing
that if they want something that they're
really putting that effort in and that's
what I don't know if you've seen that
quote in the book where I was talking
about my coach when I was in Houston
where yeah he's he told me that he said
the hardest thing for me is going to be
playing with people who don't care as
much as I do
all right and so
that is still and always will be the
struggle
another struggle
is putting yourself in in your son's
shoes and realizing like
the chance that he could ever you know
fulfill the big the big shoes that that
you've you know created is is basically
an impossibility like it's going to be
you know so
how do you raise him in a healthy way
around expectations and you know parent
in a way where he doesn't feel that that
burden you know and can fall in love
with basketball on his own terms you
know I make sure I have these
conversations too with them like I
because everywhere he goes he's in your
Shadow so what does that do to you know
a young person no question and so these
are the conversations that we have
I could just being open about it right
because he's my namesake too right and
so
I've told him I don't know how many
times I could care less if he plays
basketball like I was so happy when he
played baseball when he played soccer
but also
your name who you are your your life
you can't change that right you're here
like you're in it right even though it's
going to be tough
no one is going to feel sorry for you I
am sorry like no one is going to feel
sorry for you most of the times when you
walk in any room when someone sees you
or when someone hears your name
they're going to judge you immediately
they're going to say It's Your Privilege
you're this you're that it's going to be
up to you to not care
or to change that
right and one way that you can do that
is by the hard work or do the work like
if I walk into somewhere and someone
asks me yo you need anything and I'd be
like yeah I need y'all to order me some
food I need a drink I need a cocktail I
need a such and such somebody gonna be
like I was expecting him to be maybe
like you know which you can't control
what other people gonna think about you
and I and I have this conversation all
the time with him and my daughter
you don't get to pick and choose when
your privilege Suits You
right yeah because
when he comes to an NBA game he gets to
go back in the locker room you get to go
this you get to go do that
now
when people are looking at you or saying
this and that about this like you don't
really get a chance to to pick and
choose when the private shoots you right
you want you get one you get the other
yeah you still uh bring them to practice
yes yeah yes also explain the philosophy
behind that because I think that's
interesting yes so
um
it's funny Monty Williams who's now the
Detroit Pistons coach
um he was my coach the past three years
and it's more of my family than my coach
because he coached me back in New
Orleans uh my sixth year in the league
which was his first head coaching job uh
when I got to Phoenix
uh I asked coach I was like coach you
ever bring Elijah to practice or Micah
those is two boys
and Elijah is one of the top players in
the country now he's he was top five
Rising sophomore in the country and at
the time coach was like nah try not to
you know bring them to to practice and
Sam presti when I play in OKC you
couldn't bring family to the practice
facility and Sam is a great guy but I
told him
that's [__] I'm away from my family
so much but the reason why I think it's
important to bring your kids to the gym
to see the work is because
their advantage is not their last name
like I said that's their disadvantage
right like I said when they walk in
someone's going to judge them so if my
kids are always walking into school
saying yeah yeah my dad playing the NBA
my dad what should dad do
I don't know just playing the NBA you
know like I want my kids to see that I'm
at the gym practice at 11. I want them
to see that I'm there at eight I want
them to see what practice look like it's
a hard grind because when Dad can't be
at such and such dad ain't just hanging
out yeah no having that
um real healthy appreciation for the
actual work part of it the hard work
ethic and and that like uh reflex to
move towards uh the challenging workout
not run away from it it's like your
family you said your family helped you
with your races right sure so the fact
that your family got a chance to see
like if Dad isn't here early in the
morning when I wake up dad is not just
somewhere hanging out you know what I
mean like he's he's he's what he's he's
doing this because of this yeah and you
think they're getting it
I hope so is it working I mean you just
never know yeah I mean I'll say this
about the book there were sometimes
things that happened with my parents or
with my granddad or whatnot that I
didn't appreciate till I was older right
I didn't really appreciate my parents
enough until I had kids of my own that's
the way it works exactly yeah what is it
that you want people to get out of the
book oh man I think one of the biggest
things
um I want people to understand
the importance and the values of like
relationships real relationships and how
important they are and I hope in the
book you can get a sense of of me and
who I am but also more so about my
grandfather just about who he was as a
man and how
when you lose somebody
like even though you lose them in the
flesh right
they don't ever actually leave you
and even though it was 20 years ago that
that this happened there's a lot of
emotions or whatnot that I'd never
talked about that I experienced through
writing this book but just know that
you never get over it it's never like a
week a month or a year and that's okay
you know and I I have pockets now where
I'll be on the bus headed to a game and
I'll listen to that song My Soul has
been anchored and I literally be in the
bus like with my head up against the
window with tears in my eyes just
thinking about my granddad then I wipe
my face
and go to go to work yeah it's right
there beneath the surface I mean I saw
it earlier and you know I was texting
with Jessica
um earlier about like hey you know Chris
is coming in like you know what should
we talk like what what do people not
know like what would be you know a
thread that I could pull that I'm not
going to find on Google because you know
him so well and and she was saying that
um the process of writing the book for
you was just as you described it like it
was a very emotional experience for you
to revisit
um your relationship with this man and
kind of marinate in that and and she
shared one example where you were you
were trying to paint the picture of some
experience or some scene or some setting
where you were with him and it would it
just became so real that you got
emotional and you had to like yeah like
take a break man like those emotions for
you are clearly like still very much
alive and just under the surface of your
skin yeah I did the audio version of my
book
right so like reading it yeah I would
get out of practice and I have two hours
slotted with two guys that were in New
York like via like zoom and put the
headphones on and I would I did that for
maybe a month couple months like two
hours every day I would be reading and
that's when it really really got hard
for me and a few times throughout the
process I had to stop because
I tried to make it so vivid
in the book that when I'm reading it out
loud it immediately took me back to my
grandmother's funeral it immediately
took me right back to my grandfather's
funeral and so a lot of that stuff like
I said as family members you don't you
don't talk you don't discuss some of
those things everybody just sort of
deals with it in their own way and they
move on and it was uh I mean he saw like
you said earlier like that stuff never
leaves you yeah
um a big theme of this show is as I was
talking about earlier like change like
how do we change like what is the what
is the you know engine of change how do
you create the desire to change and the
belief in your own ability to change and
as somebody who has become very
successful how do you think of yourself
as somebody who is you know a voice for
change in the world and you know you're
somebody who through your
entrepreneurship and your you know the
Investments that you're making in you
know very you know kind of certain
sectors of the economy your production
company your your foundation all of this
is oriented around change or creating a
better world so what is the you know how
would you kind of phrase the operating
philosophy behind that and how you think
about like how you can you know use what
you have to you know create that better
world
um I think one of the biggest things is
community
right if you look at any business plan
anything that uh tries to grow it's all
about Community right about sharing with
others and finding that connectivity
that we may be from different
backgrounds I mean at the end of the day
it's the premise of my book my book is
about my grandfather but there's other
people who've had mentors and family
members that they were connected to like
that and so the importance of community
and sharing your experiences with other
people and not necessarily forcing it on
people because even like with a
plant-based lifestyle or anything a lot
of times people don't want things forced
on them but sometimes you gotta nudge it
you know you gotta keep at least giving
them the information and it may take
them a while to actually try it and um
when I think about change right I just
think about stacking days
stacking days my son is is small right
he's small just like I was and I've
talked to him about the training and how
hard it is and this that and the third
but he's he's finally starting to see a
little bit of change right in his game
or whatever and his ability and all I
keep telling him is
just keep stacking days just keep
stacking days as long as you keep
stacking days I promise you I promise
you you will see the change but
my coach used to always say everything
that you want is on the other side of
heart right he had another I think I
said in the book he said reps removed
out right reps removed out my biggest
frustration with my son used to be we
would go outside at the house and he
would shoot a shot and he'd be mad he'd
be like dang I'm like what you mad for
you don't get up enough reps
you know so those are the those are the
only things you can control anyway yep
your effort and the consistency of your
effort right there's a quote uh in the
book that I love which is hard work is
my preferred language and I try to speak
it fluently like that's [__] great
yeah you know yeah just stack it up
that's all you can do and walk away what
is your relationship to failure also
like missing that shot is it a big deal
or are you just moving on another rep
another rep another rep
I was in the gym last night I was
telling you with with the kid
um Mercy Mercy Miller last night
um
we had to end this drill we had to end
with this drill that I do where you
shoot a three in this corner
and then you run to the other end of the
Court shoot a three in this corner run
to this corner
come to this corner right so that's four
shots then you go to this Wing five that
Wing six this Wing seven this Wing eight
top of the key Nine this top ten yeah
non-stop so Sprint Sprint 10 shots gotta
make seven out of ten and we're done
with the workout for the day
um I went knocked it out what not now
Mercy gotta go ten for ten I want eight
eight I went eight out of ten Mercy's
Mercy's turn to go
first time he I think he might have got
five out of ten
win again didn't get it one again didn't
get it one again didn't get it kept
getting the six out of ten and he would
have to because you had to just make
seven seven out of ten he'd get to the
last one missed it he might have did
this drill
10 times
10 times and my son was there too and I
told Chris I said listen Mercy can work
out with me any day because he didn't
complain
he didn't do nothing this kid is about
to be a senior in high school he didn't
complain
he just
kept breathing I kept talking to him
like don't worry about it just keep keep
going keep going and sure enough
after 10 11 tries he got it he got it
and I I appreciated that from him and I
told him at the end of our workout
because he was like man appreciate you
letting me come work I said no thank you
because you make it fun for me and
that's the fun part about having 12 kids
in the NBA having all of these young
kids coming up and training would have
been working out with him because that's
that's the exciting part for me is to
know that when I'm done playing I'll
still be watching and be like man yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that's cool man and I'm sure you know
within the NBA because you're you know
more of an elder Statesman now you have
all these young players who are you know
looking up to you for that kind of
guidance and for you they're trying to
recognize like that that brings you Joy
you know to kind of get back in that way
I think I think it's cool definitely you
are going to make a good owner man when
are they gonna you got all this VHS
footage of your whole life is there
going to be a documentary are you making
a movie out of this book we
it's crazy man we have worked with
Disney on a movie about 61. oh yeah we
had done it it got like to production Oh
you mean like before the book like a
whole like a narrative and then we were
waiting for it to get green lit and it
did not
crazy right Welcome to Hollywood exactly
yeah but with all that footage maybe a
little doc something yeah something
um final thing man what is it what's the
deal with the bowling oh man you bowl I
mean I bowl like anybody bills you know
but you own a bowling team like you're
like bowling obsessed lax's yeah yeah so
uh growing up my dad was an avid bowler
me and my brother used to sit in we used
to sit in bowling alleys with my dad in
Bowling leagues you know full of
cigarette smoke and french fries that's
what everything smelled like and
you know like my dad is seriously like a
superhero to us anything my dad did we
wanted to do everything so when my dad
hooped we wanted a hoop he was a
die-hard Dallas Cowboys fan that was us
you know everything so when he bowled we
went right right along with him I want
to say when I was like a senior in high
school my parents gifted us a bowling
ball for Christmas mine my bowling ball
was a red white and blue it looked like
the ABA basketball and my brothers was a
brown ball that looked like a regular
basketball and so then we bowled all the
time in high school and college that's
where we go with our friends and then
when I got to the league I started doing
a bowling tournament on ESPN
cool it's fine it's one of those things
that like I know I say I golf now but
bowling is something that
everybody can do you can do it you know
like my I had a like one of my
granddad's Brothers he was 80 years old
still in the bowling league
right yeah so it's just fun and easy
that's cool man
um well I gotta get you out of here uh I
could I could hold you hostage all day
man but uh this is super fun I mean I
you're an inspiration uh I really you
know love the way that you lead by
example
and you teach uh through your actions
and you comport yourself with you know
so much grace and dignity and and you
know gratitude also which you mentioned
earlier which I think is huge and you
know I'm a fan dude yeah I'm a fan so I
you know best of luck with the book it's
it was really fun to read it and learn
about your life and I get my child and I
will come back and interview you I got
some more questions all right uh anytime
man any time uh so uh any any parting
words for
the uh aspiring athlete out there
somebody's trying to tap into a little
bit more Mastery into their life yeah
um I mean you hear all these sayings all
the time where they say you're only
going to get out of it what you put into
it but um I would say fall in love with
the work
right like I always say about the NBA
I've had guys I've had teammates and
it's fine some guys be like I don't
watch basketball when I go home because
I play too much I don't know I'd be like
listen
you think if somebody work on work on
Wall Street when they go on vacation
they not checking
um the stock exchange you know but to
each his own right so
if you fall in love with the work aspect
of it then the success in the accolades
that come with it but you got to fall in
love with the work don't just fall in
love with the the showers of people
telling you how good and great you are
at it like you if you fall in love with
the work aspect of it then every
everything else I promise to fall into
place
I spit in fire straight from the mouth
with CP3 thanks buddy that was really
cool appreciate it man it's an honor to
talk to you thank you yeah thanks man
peace
[Music]